even if we cut dramatically in our
carbon emissions now we wouldn't really
be able to see the impact by 2050 and we
would only see a smaller impact towards
the end of the century so most of global
warming is simply going to happen if we
have to face up to that we have to say
we should also talk about adaptation now
this doesn't mean we shouldn't also fix
climate change but we need to look at
adaptation how should we tackle this
well we again love to believe that this
is something that individuals and
companies could do something about but
fundamentally this is much more about
what should societies do the simple and
very broad bruh a brushed answer is
societies that are rich that are well
structured that have good infrastructure
a much better able to deal with all the
problems that the world throws at it
including global warming for instance if
you look at hurricanes if a hurricane
hits Florida it costs a lot of money but
it's still only a couple percent in
terms of GDP of Florida and it kills
very few people if it hits Honduras it
will cost easily one-third two-thirds of
Honduras GDP and it will eradicate tens
of thousands of people so fundamentally
it's about having better planning it's
about having better infrastructure it's
about having better ability to withstand
problems that the future will throw at
us this has the advantage of not just
being able to protect us against global
warming but also all the other problems
that we probably haven't even started
thinking about you